very very small thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's
a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1
a major mistake would be you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern but you forget
and you say you do a reach hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake so with the
minor mistake let's say pattern one for example there's 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to
maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being
it needs to be absolutely perfect to get to not get a deduction of 0.1
so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 mistakes
so what would that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll just
calculate the score at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left when you
turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously we do want to try and avoid any of
these major mistakes so after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the
presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a score of six this six is actually
up into three parts so we have one two three here so with this one for a score of two is your power
and speed your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also scored out of
two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one whether it's your blocks
your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you do you need to be nice and strong and
strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that in that
category so the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm when you do start your pattern there is
a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way through it's not slow all the
way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of
work on your rhythm and that's also scored out of two the last bit is your
expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically how loud you shout
so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so say you're doing your pattern really
well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but you're not shouting very loud
or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell you're not really confident you're a little
bit nervous so that's why we need to kind of improve on as well so i'll just come around to
this side
so with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently so
if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where where the judges actually mark
you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so say you did uh you did all right you
did average compared to everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so
if you're less than average
in the judges eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a one
or even at 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual uh
category you need to obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt
generally depending on the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average
that you start from so say your parent speed
was above
average average you might get scored a one point say let's say 1.4 for now i say your rhythm
was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3 but let's say you didn't
shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3 it might drop to say let's say 1.0
so with this one we'll come over uh down to this side so with this one uh as i was saying it's a
total of uh 10 so let's see and for presentation we had 0.7
1 2 3 so you added 3.7 and so you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously don't be
too discouraged if you do get uh pretty high
in your mistakes uh this is with the judges we have three judges usually at the panel and each
judge obviously it's very subjective so uh from their point of view you might have made a lot of
mistakes or you may i may have made not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three
judges and we average it out as well okay so uh say we did our uh 15 mistakes very small mistakes
so if they're all uh
minus 0.1 to be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your accuracy score
so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here so we add these numbers at
the uh after the judges are finished scoring so you would get for this pattern a 6.2 which is
actually very good
so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here
so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow uh or above and you do your patterns it's not
uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four to five so if you get a number
between uh four and five out of ten for your pattern that's actually uh generally considered
pretty good so anything above that
uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a black belt the average would say because
um we're talking here about the the higher presentation as an average
anything from five to oh two sorry five to six is actually considered uh pretty pretty good
and anything over a seventh is actually considered almost world-class so if you get a seventh for any
of your patterns you generally need to pad yourself on the back of a black belt so it's pretty good
did an amazing job so we just went through our poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a
4.0 presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get
two scores that we add up and we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was uh i was
judge number one i would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe he saw
a couple more mistakes than i did so maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a
five point something another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get
the three numbers and then we'd average that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys so
make sure you enjoy your poomsae competitions and anytime make sure obviously you record down
your numbers
so minor errors major errors real time we cannot post a video but you can
do this while you're this is during you're watching your video but afterwards
you can read power and speed zero two okay so afterwards you can read this
during the video plus plus
and then it will be automatically calculated at the end okay and there's no like comparison
video right i'm just kind of just going on my own understanding of it yes okay
so
you
Thank you.